all right guys
bang bang i've got nikhil here i'm super
excited about this thank you
so much for joining us thanks so much
for having me man
absolutely let's just jump right into
your background i think that you've got
kind of a really interesting story kind
of help us
understand uh where you grew up what you
did uh
school and then before you became a
venture capitalist
for sure so i grew up in england my
parents immigrated there from india
and so i was born in the uk uh lived
there until i was 13 before we moved to
the bay area
and so i went from reading in england to
the heart of silicon valley and that
totally changed my life you know i got
to learn about entrepreneurship
and everything happening here in
technology when i was in high school
and that led me to start working on
startup ideas basically from day one
in college uh so i went went to
princeton
you know revived the entrepreneurship
club on campus there
uh worked on a number of different
startup ideas one of them actually
turned into a real company called artsy
which is a
marketplace for original art today and
then
the lightbulb went off for me that at
some point i'd love to be on the other
side of the table
uh to try investing i had the chance to
start out as an intern at insight
venture partners in new york
joined there full time and then just
kept going and
uh and you know ended up joining shasta
ventures back in 2012 spent almost eight
years there
and so i've spent um basically the whole
last decade in investing
yeah what was the desire to
uh invest even if you'd already started
a couple of companies
i think um you know the the
the chance to meet with some of the most
talented people every day
uh was the thing that you know
entrepreneurs was the thing that got me
most excited to to try my hand at
investing i just
felt like wow you know that chance to
spot the next google the next tesla the
next
um you know huge company
and get a front row seat to uh
to being part of that journey as an
investor was
the sort of spark that attracted me the
most and frankly is still the thing that
i get most excited about every day i
just love getting to
spend time with entrepreneurs and i
think it's very hard if you
don't love that to you know love venture
capital investing because there's
a lot of great ways to make money um and
frankly easier ways to make money than
than early stage investing but the
chance to meet with these
incredibly talented people to see them
in in the nascent stages of building
their company and
and then to get the chance to be a part
of a few of their journeys as an
investor
is just an amazing privilege absolutely
and you recently talked a lot about kind
of this idea of a solo capitalist um
it's interesting because you came from
more of a traditional venture
uh investing um kind of structure and
organization
uh what was the fascination or kind of
the impetus for
uh being intrigued by the solo
capitalist
kind of structure yeah so back in
um march i knew that i was going to end
up leaving shasta
later this year and and so i started
to write and um i wrote
up like a seven-page memo about
the current status of the venture
capital industry and where i thought it
was going to go
and it was really for myself to think
through where do i want to play in this
ecosystem moving forward
and one of the sections of that piece
was
about the rise of solo capitalists and i
i sort of tried to define those people
very specifically which
are folks who are raising funds
that are greater than 50 million dollars
they have the ability to
lead uh rounds that are 5 million and
above
and they're playing at a higher level
with
higher dollars than the super angel
investors
of a decade ago and there's a bunch of
these folks
who have cropped up and are competing on
leading seed rounds leading series a
rounds
maybe even leading series b and c rounds
against traditional firms
and so i started writing about them for
myself
and started talking to a number of other
people in the ecosystem about them
earlier this year and then that's what
led me to finally publish this piece in
july
where i think i was the first one to use
this term solo capitalist and
and define it um
and uh and again it was it was a selfish
motivation for me to figure out where do
i want to play in this ecosystem but to
also
uh expose it for both founders and other
investors
as um a new class of of investor that's
that's that's rising up in the ecosystem
um
so that was that was the impetus
absolutely and maybe talk a little bit
more about
kind of where you see those specific
types of investors fitting into the
ecosystem so you kind of drew this like
big industry map and then identified
solar capitalists as one of many
different types of roles
but how did you kind of see that uh
evolving over time yeah i mean
so number one i think we're gonna see
more and more individual investors
who attract founders and
um and more and more founders who get
excited to work with
individual investors instead of
traditional firms and the reason i feel
that way
is if you look at the traditional firm
world anyway today
you have uh you know certain individuals
usually it's actually like one or two
individuals at any given firm
who are the real draw for founders to
that firm
um and so you know the individualization
of
venture capital has been happening for a
long time
and i think the solar capitalist
movement is the sort of purest
manifestation of that trend
um and and so where i see them fitting
is uh these people like
elod gill ray tonsing lockheed groom
um josh buckley minolhassen uh
you know addy leona uh nico whittenborn
there's several of them and actually at
some point i should publish a follow-up
post that
that tries to name all of them or have
like an ongoing list of a bunch of them
but i think we'll see more people like
this number one in the ecosystem
we'll see more of them leading rounds
instead of the traditional firms leading
you know a seed round or series a round
in particular
and then the big question is how long
can these individual investors sort of
practice their craft
uh before they end up turning you know
into firms themselves with more people
around them
and i think that's a big question um
because it is hard to scale
as a solo capitalist if one day you're
you're handling
you know 50 60 portfolio companies
you're on the boards of 30 of them
uh that's a challenging place to be and
our business notoriously doesn't scale
anyway
and so i think that's kind of a big um
unknown question
yeah i think the the whole idea of
you're basically unbundling a venture
capital firm with the solo capitalist
and then at some point it
has it in everything it just gets
bundled back together again right
yeah i think i think that's that's
potentially likely i'm sure we're gonna
see
um a handful of them join together as
well and and raise funds together
which will be very interesting too uh i
think the final point that's
that's not noteworthy and important to
make is
the limited partner ecosystem the lps
that invest in venture funds
um these are university endowments
family offices
funded funds pension funds they
have increasingly become comfortable
with the idea of a sold gp
and the fact they are stepping up and
committing to these funds is a huge
reason for why they can exist
in the ecosystem today and so i just
thought it's important for folks to
understand that aspect as well
absolutely i want to kind of go through
a couple of companies that you've
invested in really with the goal of
trying to unpack
kind of the investment process or how
you develop an investment thesis
the first one i figured that we would
start with is class dojo
maybe tell us a little bit about what
this company does how you came across
them and then what ultimately got you
excited about investing
yeah class dojo has a special place in
my heart because it was the first
company
um that i got to work on as an
investment at shasta
and so we ended up leading the series a
round back in march of 2013
and back then class dojo was a
behavioral management
product for teachers to be able to use
in the classroom
and basically classes will help teachers
manage behavior and make their
classrooms uh happier
and more productive um what class dojo
is today
seven years later is a communication
platform for
teachers parents and students and also a
place for parents to
to have more content and um
and more engagement with their kids
beyond school uh
and that's actually the way that the
business monetizes is that we
uh we have a subscription offering for
parents
um and uh and we can upsell that to
any parents on the platform would we are
free to teachers and and always will be
um and so back in 2013
what got us excited about class dojo was
it was organically growing
to um teachers around the country and
around the world
and um you know traditional companies in
education technology
had been selling into districts and
selling into school systems
but what class dojo was doing was
actually giving away a product for free
to teachers and thereby organically
spreading
and so the company number one had a
whole bunch of early signs of product
market fit when we invested
number two we felt that there was this
chance for them to unlock
uh an amazing business model with
parents down the road
because they had heavy engagement and
retention
of parents already on the product but
they weren't yet offering
parents anything more than the ability
to
see what teachers are saying about their
kids um
and and and so that was kind of the
second part of the thesis is hey
this is a chance to actually build a
consumer education technology company
um and then the third part of the thesis
was
uh mission driven founders who
were working on their life's work and
i think the thing that got us over the
edge about class dojo was
the belief that sam and liam the
founders
were people who would you know stick to
to building this for the next decade or
more
um who are incredibly kind of driven
by um the mission of making
kids and teachers and classrooms uh
happier uh more productive
and um and and and i would say that's
uh that's also very much played out in
the last
seven years since we invested so that's
a little bit about
kind of three pillars of the investment
thesis
what got us excited about it um and
you know seven years later uh really
proud of this investment
you know that the company is now tens of
millions in revenue
with um parents who subscribe and so
we've unlocked that
um that business model that we predicted
um
and uh you know the the product is used
by
tens of millions of um you know parents
students and teachers around the world
uh it's used by most of them for free
and
um and you know i think for the founders
this is still
you know a decades-long journey ahead um
i wouldn't be surprised if it ends up
being the last job for
for both of them absolutely how do you
test for or try to unpack that
commitment that
mission-driven element of a founder
right you know there's a lot of
investors who will talk about
uh the easiest way for a company to fail
is for the founders basically to give up
so how do you kind of unpack that during
diligence and as you get to know
somebody
yeah i mean i think this is the most in
some ways it's the hardest part of
of early stage investing because so much
of the decision ends up being about the
people
and about these founders ability
to sort of you know get through wall off
the wall to to make their vision a
reality
um to grip through everything the
persevere
their ability to prioritize well their
ability to hire well
and so you can try to test for some of
this stuff at the early stage
but oftentimes you're making a sort of
gut judgment on the founders and it's
probably the most subjective part of
early stage investing i would say with
class student in particular
you know we uh we spent a bunch of time
with sam and liam the founders
i remember going on a walk with sam the
ceo
uh as we were actually right after we
had decided to give them a term sheet as
we were trying to win them over
and coming away from that hour-long walk
feeling
wow this is someone that i'd want to
work for
and this is someone who you can tell
just how authentic
the desire to build this is to him and
again it's really hard to quantify that
but i think once you have
met with a bunch of founders and once
you've had some
you know recognition of uh what it takes
to commit
and to stick to something you can start
to see patterns in
those extraordinary founders who who do
end up
figuring it out um and i think we had
elements of that that we saw in the
class dojo founders
early stage yeah that's awesome another
company is
canva which uh many people may not know
but this is an absolute
monster of a business uh talk a little
bit about that one and kind of what the
thesis was and how you guys got
comfortable making the investment
yeah i mean canvas is an absolutely
amazing company which
you know has a software platform that
enables
anyone to design anything and so
this is a company that today is hundreds
of millions in
ar a profitable business growing really
quickly
i like to say to people that i hope one
day
canada becomes a public company and i
think it'll be
the closest to zoom of any financial
profile s1 that i've seen in recent
memory
um if that if that public offering
happens
for canva one day because it's just an
extraordinary business
on sort of every uh financial metric
but when we invested in the company it
was 2014
so a year off the class dojo
and the company had launched about six
months prior to
our investment um and like class dojo
the first pillar of the thesis was a
whole bunch of early signs of product
market fit
so um the canva product in month six
month seven
had hundreds of thousands of monthly
active users
those users were creating over a million
designs a month
you could see in the early cohort
retention that 30 40 50
of every cohort was still using the
product and
and sticking around and then there was
this subset of
tens of thousands of users who had
already created
tens of designs each on canva and um
were basically using it for everything
everything from
you know social media infographics to
slide decks to
um to editing photos
um to flyers and and so
and the final thing was the product was
growing 30 40
50 organically every month without the
company doing anything to drive that
growth
and so you could see on a whole bunch of
dimensions growth engagement retention
um that canva was special in like month
six months seven
it wasn't yet monetizing and so there
was this question around hey how's it
going to make money
actually similar question now do they
think about it to
to class dojo but we believed that
there were enough dollars going off the
design that one day
there would be a premium subscription
that people would pay for to use
canberra
and so you know i would say we we got
over that
that hump that there wasn't any revenue
yet
and then again the final thing that was
just amazing about canva was
um these two founders melanie perkins
and cliff obrecht
um who were out in sydney australia
uh you know building this thing you know
canva was actually
um the second business they'd been
working on they'd worked on a yearbook
business beforehand
and found it was actually difficult to
design that yearbook
and they needed great software to to
make the design
and so canva was born out of a very
authentic pain point
for melanie cliff and that early team
and you could just tell their insane
passion for what they were working on
and that passion was translated into
a lot of different aspects of that
product and a lot of reasons for why
those early customers loved the product
um
but uh you know it's just been a
remarkable journey since then to see
what they've done in the last six years
and
it's definitely exceeded uh you know our
wildest expectations
absolutely and when you look at a
company like canva
obviously as you start to get data you
can really begin to understand
um you know is this working or is this
not to some degree
how do you get comfortable investing
before there's that data or before
you see that that product like walk us
through maybe kind of your process or
some of the things you keep in mind
uh when you are pre-product pre-data
pre-revenant
such a great question i mean i think
again
this is really hard you know for
for um every investor who invested in
uh one of these generational companies
pre-product
uh and certainly early signs of product
market fit
i always tip my hat to those people
because
i think that's uh way harder than
investing once there are some
early signs of product market fit and to
be honest with you you know most of the
investments that i've made in my venture
career have been
once there are some early signs of
product market fit
the handful of places where i've broken
that rule
have been where i've just felt so
compelled by a founder
or so compelled by a market opportunity
or so compelled by
maybe an early mock-up of the product
that i was able to get
get there conviction-wise without seeing
any early data
and then a few of my regrets too in
investing
have been that way so for instance when
i looked at robin hood at the series a
there wasn't early data that showed a
whole bunch of signs of product market
fit
you know there was a wait list of
hundreds of thousands of
uh users who wanted the product but the
product was only in the hands of
like 100 people in the beta you know the
thing that i was super excited about was
seeing that product
in action on the test flight and seeing
how powerful
stock trading was on mobile and
believing that wow
this could change the whole uh the whole
industry
and that's of course what um beijing
vlad
the robin hood founders believed but i
think those are
really hard bets in venture capital to
make where
you know something isn't working yet and
i think you just have to rely on
an instinct around either the the
founders the product or the market
but it's instinct versus um versus data
the obvious answer to how you compensate
for essentially taking more risk would
be
you'd want to pay a different price for
for what you're investing in
are there other things that you take
into consideration when you are taking
more risk other than just price
yeah i mean i think it's it's
it's price but i think you also
uh are thinking i certainly think about
how big of a swing is this because i
think if you
are taking you know more of a risk
then you want to believe there's just
much more of a reward and some of that
is related to the entry price
but some of that's of course related to
um
you know the ultimate exit prize uh
uh prize not not price um
maybe i'll i'll use that phrase one day
uh
you know so again this is something
that's very hard to quantify
especially because some markets are
unintuitive
and and and hard to predict you know how
big they can become
but uh you know where i would take
pre-product market fit risk would be on
someone working on a disruptive
technology that maybe no one else
is working on or no one else could be
working on uh you know i'd like to think
if i saw
something like spacex or tesla at the
very early stage like that's the type of
thing that's
worth doing um pre any signs of product
market fit
because you believe that holy [ __ ] if
they pull this off it could be massive
um and i i i would get less excited
about
an incremental idea um pre-product
market fit if that makes sense
absolutely another business that's a
little bit different than the first two
we talked about
you've invested in is called color it's
in a whole different industry maybe talk
to us a little bit about
that business and kind of what was so
intriguing about it
yeah so color um collagenomics
uh is a genomic testing uh business
which started off with uh you know
a cheap and more convenient way
for for anyone to get
a cancer genomic screening test and so
there's a number of different genomic
markers that
uh that we now know have um
a higher level of likelihood to uh
ultimately lead to cancer than
than than sort of if you don't have
those those markers
and the original color test uh was
a fast uh accurate and cheap way to get
that
um get that screening uh the company has
evolved a bunch since
our original investment which was i
believe in 2017.
um today for instance uh
they've done an incredible job in the
last eight months
spinning up uh a testing business for
covid19
and um you know if you're in a place
like the bay area
uh you know colors testing sites are all
over the place
and are one of the the fastest and
cheapest ways to get a cobia 19 test
uh which has been uh terrific for a
whole number of reasons in the last
eight months
um you know this was a company that uh
i think the primary reason we made the
investment was frankly the founders
we got really excited about uh elod gill
and atman laraki uh who were the two
founders of color they they founded a
company previously
a lot of people know elod now because of
his uh
investing activity the books that he's
he's written
um ottman is the ceo of color and sort
of
more under the radar but equally if not
more accomplished
an incredible angel investor an
incredible operator
um and so we thought that this was
uh just an incredible team that was
getting built
to work on the intersection of biology
healthcare and computing which is an
area that i actually studied in
undergrad in
in college i i majored ultimately in
molecular biology and so
i had a passion for this area for a long
time and i've been looking for
a team that could go execute against
something really interesting
in the space and color stood out to us
as
just an extraordinary team working on a
really interesting problem and a market
that had potential to expand
and so that was actually very simply the
investment thesis we definitely couldn't
have predicted for instance that they
would get into covet 19 testing
uh three four years later but i think
that's kind of
the reason to take a swing on a really
high quality team
is the chance for them to to iterate
over time to find these even more
compelling opportunities than their
original business
and i think that's right now the story
of of color
yeah and it's so funny to hear kind of
each explanation of these businesses
because the team is so important
and if you look at some of the great
businesses today right whether it is
amazon whether it's twitter a lot of
these businesses
uh either started out doing something
completely different and evolved or
they've drastically expanded what
they've done
and ultimately like that is how you
scale and build very very large you know
successful valuable businesses
and so just like people are buying into
jack dorsey or
um you know jeff bezos or mark
zuckerberg you're really doing the exact
same thing at the earliest stages of a
business
you're just finding people that may not
be known as you know the person who can
go do this yet
for sure i mean i think if you look at
the arc of
um almost every amazing business
they had an act one that you know
got to a bunch of signs of product
market fit a good business
maybe a great business in some cases but
then these companies had
an act two and act three that uh
even better businesses that expanded the
size of the addressable market as well
um
and you know that's the story over and
over again if you look at
tesla from you know roadster to model s
to model three
to you know what they are today um
amazon from books to the everything
store to aws
um shopify from e-commerce stores to now
you know financing and a platform and
all this other stuff that they've
done it's the story over and over again
and that
story relies on incredible um
entrepreneurs
and leadership teams uh delivering on a
successful
transition from an act one to an act two
and act three
and and those things are just not gonna
be present in an early stage company so
they're
they're fundamentally things that you're
betting on the team to do
absolutely um i wanna switch gears a
little bit and talk about a couple of
topics that you've written
about i always like to kind of get you
to expand on things you've already kind
of put out into the public sphere you've
probably gotten a bunch of feedback on
uh things that people agree with things
that people don't agree with and so
maybe we can kind of dig a little bit
deeper
the first is this idea of democratizing
access being a kind of
valuable thing and you broke it down
into this framework of
essentially cheaper free or more
convenient so
can you kind of talk through why that
specific framing
um and then maybe some of the the ways
you've seen this applied and been
successful in the market
for sure um you know so when i reflect
on a lot of the investments that i've
made in the last decade
a lot of them actually come down to this
thesis of democratizing access
which is uh we know
um that there's this product or service
that you know a bunch of people love
a bunch of people use but it's not yet
accessible to the broader population
and so a company comes in makes it more
accessible
and that expands the size of the market
opportunity that's that's
the thesis in a nutshell and so
i started to think about okay what are
some of the most powerful companies that
i've seen that have democratized access
their companies let's take fintech as
one uh
area right robin hood is a company
that's democratized access to stock
trading and they did that by
uh by making it free uh and on mobile
um you know coinbase is an example of a
company that's democratized access to
uh people you know holding
buying selling uh cryptocurrencies
and i would argue that the primary way
they've done that is by making it more
convenient
um they've actually you know it's it's
actually more expensive
uh on coinbase than on a bunch of other
platforms because the coinbase fee is
more expensive
but it's more convenient and then
uh you know there are a bunch of
companies
for instance i recently invested in a
company called alto ira
which enables people to invest in um
in alternative assets out of their
retirement funds and i think you might
be involved in companies
as well in this space um but that
company is make
has made it cheaper to um to invest
in alternative assets out of your
retirement funds like your ira
uh than a bunch of the traditional
incumbents in that space that
make it super expensive to do that uh
and so
you know i think these three axes
cheaper
more convenient and then three are the
three axes
through which most companies democratize
access and that's what i was trying to
flesh out in that blog post
how important is it for a company to
have
two of three versus one of three or
three of three versus two of three like
is there kind of
uh additional value that is captured by
having multiple components so like ulta
is a good example
not only is it cheaper but also it's
more convenient right so they kind of
check two of the three boxes
how do you think about that yeah i think
that's right i think you know i didn't
make this point
explicit in my post but i did get
uh feedback around it and i've reflected
on it and i think
the key is to probably spike on one of
those three dimensions
so either you know you're spiking the
consumers because
you're offering this thing that used to
be really expensive and now it's cheaper
or
something that's actually pretty cheap
but now it's free or this is just way
more convenient than any other approach
and i think
so so i think you have to spike on one
of them and i think ideally
you want to be more convenient as well
as free or more convenient as well as
cheaper
and so again it probably deserves at
some point of follow-up and i'd love for
others out there who've thought about it
to follow up and and and sort of push
back
one of the the best parts about writing
is as i think you know as well you're
getting your thoughts out there and then
having a bunch of really small people
respond to them
um and so i think you're right that
that's it's likely multiple that
lead to the sort of deadly combination
yeah
another topic you've written about is
kind of the consumerization
of health care uh when people think of
healthcare they don't necessarily think
of
user-friendly uh interfaces or user
experiences that leave you delighted
uh i think what you wrote about was was
really one compelling but also two kind
of gives people a peek into
the future of health care so maybe
unpack that a little bit
i think broadly speaking this healthcare
is one of the
giant categories uh especially in the us
that has actually become more expensive
over the last
several decades and has become
a worse experience for a lot of people
and so there's so much to do in this
area i think if you have to pick one
segment of the economy that is the
one of the biggest and the most painful
for
uh the majority of people it's probably
healthcare and there's so much to do
here
what i've been encouraged by is there
are now
finally a number of success stories of
companies
that um that are consumerizing
healthcare that have figured out
a way to get to the end user the the
patient
um and deliver something that's just a
way better experience
for them and in many cases they've
actually gone direct to the consumer
in how they've gone to market as well
and so as an example of this
uh about three years ago i spent time
with a number of players
in the market who were working on a
combination of telemedicine and
pharmacy delivery to enable a much
better
consumer healthcare experience and so
i'm thinking about companies like
hymns row
nurex and pill club these are kind of
the four players that
are all hundreds of millions in revenue
now um
through a combination of uh telemedicine
and pharmacy
and if you think about that they've
basically eliminated
multiple steps that are painful in the
existing health care experience for many
people
you know they've eliminated the step of
having to go to the doctor to
um tell a doctor about something that's
going on with them and then
go to the pharmacy to get the
prescription
and and then maybe sometimes go back to
pick it up um
you know all of that is replaced through
one uh online
mobile-friendly experience um forgetting
things like
uh birth control um
medication uh hair loss medication etc
um and so as i started you know these
companies were the first that i saw
um really have true signs of product
market fit directly with consumers in
healthcare
and um and so i've been thinking about
this thesis uh
really for the last three four years you
know color feeds into this thesis
pill club and other of my investments
fits into this thesis
and i wrote the post because i'd love to
make more investments
around this because i think number one
there's a ton of
um you know potential return there
to to be made for an early stage
investor like me
but number two i think it's really
important for our society that we
uh we build more of these products yeah
and what's really
interesting about roe and hims and i
think a couple of the others
a lot of them got started right around
the same time right and so what i've
always wondered is
is it something where one entrepreneur
kind of identifies a market opportunity
word spreads quickly and there's two or
three fast followers
or is it more of there's some inflection
point whether it's a regulatory thing
it's a technology advancement
you know something kind of opens up the
opportunity and you just have a lot of
smart people constantly thinking of
ideas and and
a number of people come to the same
conclusion around the same time
how do you kind of evaluate you know
okay there's this telemedicine plus
pharmaceutical uh
mechanism multiple companies are going
after it does that scare you away does
that
actually make you more excited because
it validates an opportunity just what's
that framework you use
so number one i think to answer your
question directly it's probably a
combination of those factors usually
that leads to a whole bunch of companies
working on
something similar at the same time and
this has happened over and over again
um uh you know so so i would say it's a
combination
in in this particular area of
telemedicine plus pharmacy i think it is
very much a combination of regulations
changing to enable
broader access to telemedicine to enable
um a prescription to be uh
made electronically and then um and then
you know delivered via mail or by korea
very easily
um you know finally
and and another market tailwind you know
around
being able to advertise direct to
consumers and
um platforms like facebook and google
uh making it more accessible for these
companies to use
to to get directly to consumers i think
also enabled
these businesses to sort of all start to
work at the same time and then
my guess is you know they all sort of
saw
the others doing well and that propelled
sort of more entrepreneurial activity
that
them all becoming a little bit more
aggressive
um and and so when i see the so to
answer your second question when i see
these types of areas
i would say i get interested often
um and then i try to figure out which is
you know the player that i want to
invest in
um within that area and what are the
types of characteristics of that
particular market that would lead to
one player becoming bigger than another
or potentially
multiple players all becoming really big
um
you know what i've learned over the
years is even though some categories may
seem that they are winner take
all most categories are actually not you
know most categories
especially ones that are expanding
rapidly um can have multiple winners
and we have seen that if you think about
you know
um transportation right
you know uber and lyft are both uh
are both successes uh especially for
early-stage investors
um in food delivery uh there's a whole
bunch of successes it isn't actually
just
ubereats and doordash and postmates
and grubhub it's also dominos for
instance right and
um which i know you're you're a big fan
of uh
but you know there can be multiple big
winners in some of these
massively expanding markets and so i
think about that too
absolutely the third topic i want to
talk about is kind of consumer
subscriptions
um it seems like uh the world has woken
up to subscriptions as if it's some new
thing that uh you know was just
discovered uh
last year or something uh you see this
with everything from the sub stacks of
the world all the way
you know to netflix etc but obviously
it's a business model that's been around
for a very very long time
why kind of bullish on this and and what
was really driving the uh
the intrigue or interest yeah so i would
say this is an area that
um i probably know the most about from
all the different
things that i've written and why i saved
it for last
yeah and next week thing you know a lot
of them i feel a little bit like a
poser writing about something or you
know an outsider looking in
you know i don't actually know that much
about it but
you know at shasta over the last eight
years i
invested in a number of subscription
businesses
both digital such as canva and class
dojo which we talked about
and uh physical you know businesses like
pilclub
which have a physical component of
delivering
in their case medication to um to their
consumers on a recurring
subscription basis and so what i
what i've actually wanted to write for
many years is
a series of posts around consumer
subscriptions and so
this was one that was kind of penned up
for a while
um and what has frustrated me about
kind of the literature in this area is
not that many people have talked about
it
you know whereas if you look at
marketplaces another business model in
the internet
um there's tons of writing about
marketplaces right you have like
all these terrific posts about you know
um
different factors of marketplaces that
make them successful such as
one that bill girly did i think about
eight years ago um
we have all these lists of like the top
marketplace companies
um the top marketplace founders but i
i've just
felt that the literature is lacking on
the subscription side
and i wanted to write a series of pieces
around that
and so that was really the the driving
force it isn't a new thesis area for me
um per se but i think one that deserves
more exploration
because of how prevalent it is um
and so hopefully people found it
interesting for that reason yeah
and how do you see consumer
subscriptions evolving
specifically through the lens of it
almost feels like there's um
jockeying might not be the right word
but there's this balance like every time
sas uh startups with kind of this
recurring revenue model
uh makes a leap forward uh it seems like
consumer subscription companies aren't
that far behind
and there's a lot of similarities in
just the subscription nature of the
revenue and things and i'm specifically
thinking through
uh you know take a company like maybe
pipe that does sort of
um you know they help to get capital to
a company without it being dilutive
and they use this recurring revenue uh
as a
way to determine how much and when
they'll give them that capital
that to me feels like a very much
sas like service that's been around
right or servicing sas companies
but now that type of stuff is trickling
into the consumer subscription space and
so
is that something that we should maybe
expect to happen
more is that something that's just like
there might be some one-off examples but
not necessarily
a trend or maybe you haven't even
thought about it that way and think
about it some other way
i think it's a really it's really
interesting point i mean
broadly speaking the way i think about
the world is that there's
less of a division between consumers
and enterprises than ever before i mean
this is kind of a theme
if you think about it we've already
talked about this in this very podcast
episode we started to talk about solar
capitalists at the beginning
and the sort of unbundling of venture
firms um
you know and now we're talking about
kind of the
unbundling to a certain extent of
businesses into
individual um you know end users and
consumers at
at those businesses and so i just think
you know there's there's a lot of
learnings
from um you know traditional enterprise
businesses that one can apply to
consumers
and traditional consumer businesses that
one can apply to enterprises
and i hope to flesh out more of this
through next big thing you know i wrote
that the second um the second issue of
the newsletter is
all about the blend uh of consumer and
enterprise and the blurring between
those lines
and so i think you're absolutely right
that there's a bunch of stuff
from software as a service um
you know b2b businesses that one can
apply to consumer businesses
and i think there's a bunch of stuff
from consumer subscription businesses
that that apply to sas
um with pipes specifically i mean the
thing that started running through my
head is
you know could you see a world in which
um
you know number one there's uh there's
some sort of alternate funding mechanism
for consumer subscription businesses
because
like sas businesses they are more
predictable
than um a non-uh subscription-based
consumer business and i
i think there should be um and then
the other thing i started to think about
is you know for the consumers of
subscription businesses
will there be financing products for for
people like you and i um that you know
enable us
to uh to somehow you know
spend more of our money on subscriptions
or sort of have more peace of mind
that when we're spending on
subscriptions um
that's not you know uh you know pushing
us into
um you know a challenging income
territory or
challenging sort of balance sheet
uh i don't know the answer to that but i
think it's an interesting idea because i
do think we're gonna see
um a bunch more proliferation of
consumer subscription services
yeah the other piece that i've thought
about and uh by no means have
answers to but but i think are
interesting questions is um
if you think of traditional uh kind of
content business let's use them as an
example right so podcast
there's a bunch of people now talking
about like oh there should be
subscription podcasts right there's
subscription
emails there's subscription uh
television and streaming and like all
these other pieces of content
and um you know theoretically that makes
sense uh there's a couple of people who
have made it work but there's also a lot
of people who have tried it and it
hasn't worked and
i always kind of start to think through
is it a business model
friction point right like is it are you
testing the business model or is it
no if it works for all these other
different types of content it will work
here it's just somebody's got to figure
out the right pricing the right
you know technology platform the right
experience
right value proposition like it you know
it's kind of the unknown a little bit
but
it always feels like there's this debate
around
um is it this is the right idea it just
hasn't been properly applied yet
or is it no the idea is wrong and
therefore everyone who tries this can
eventually you know kind of come to the
same conclusion
i think um first of all i think a lot of
things can be subscriptionized
including podcasts i think one of the
hardest things in podcasts
in particular is that we've just been
accustomed to getting them for free
and so the ad supported model especially
in the us has been dominant for
a long long period of time and so i
think when something is already free
uh moving it back to being a
paid and you know a premium subscription
model
is difficult but i still think in
podcasts we're going to see a bunch of
different attempts i think even this
morning
um spotify made a bunch of announcements
around
uh you know a premium podcast service
that was
ad-free um and i i suspected that this
is where they were going i was actually
surprised that as a premium
spot spotify subscriber i was listening
to spotted
to podcasts on spotify that still had
ads it was kind of a weird experience to
go from like never having ads in my
spotify experiences suddenly having ads
when when a podcast showed up and so
it's completely unsurprising to me that
they are
gonna go down this path i'm gonna try to
have people pay for
podcasts that don't have ads and i
suspect that we'll see a bunch of people
pay for them because it is a better
experience for a lot of people to not
listen to the ads um and then i think
like there's all these other things i
mean i don't know i think
any um any like small
business or entrepreneur has the chance
to
offer something on a subscription basis
i mean you look at like patreon which is
enabling
um the patronage model for influencers
i'm thinking a lot about like local
businesses and
you know could you imagine becoming a
subscriber to your local
pizza restaurant or um your favorite
fine dining place in your city
i mean first of all these businesses
need more predictable income than ever
before
uh second of all i think anyway people
start to think about themselves
as like patrons of their their favorite
local business and so it's a natural
existing behavior
um and so i just think there's a ton of
opportunity
yet to be explored and that's just one
small idea
um around subscriptions yeah i love the
way you think about it
the last topic i want to cover uh before
we get into the rapid fire to wrap up
is crypto um i don't think you've ever
publicly talked or definitely not uh a
lot talked about
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies what's kind
of your view
uh on the assets themselves the industry
and
whether you've ever done anything in the
space yeah
first of all i feel weird talking about
this given how much of an expert you are
in this area but i'm fascinated by it i
mean i
i started exploring um
crypto through buying bitcoin i think
back in 2013 or
maybe a bunch in 2013 and 2014
um and uh and just decided to hold
uh you know so that i have some some
small percent of my
you know net worth in in crypto assets
and of course as
those assets have risen in prices
suddenly it's a more important part of
my
my overall um net worth
you know the thing that i've always been
looking out for that i've yet to see
come to fruition
is you know an amazing uh
end user-driven consumer application or
enterprise application
that is a better experience than the
status quo
and you know the big reason for that
better experience
is is crypto but um
but that isn't the thing that that gets
people excited to use the product or the
service
it's just an underlying reason for why
the experience is way better
and um and i hope that we see more and
more products like that going forward i
mean
the obvious place that i that i think we
could see it is
um is in you know financial services
where you know you could
you could have you know a payment
product or a money transfer
product or a lending product that just
has you know way lower transaction costs
way lower fees
lower interest rates etc etc because the
underlying technology
is is um is powered by crypto
but we haven't yet seen i think someone
really come out
and and have that amazing use case um
and deliver an engineering experience
that's just you know uh broadly
applicable
um and i think when we see that the
floodgates will start to open
um i'm curious if that resonates with
you or
how you feel about that i i think you're
directionally correct like the the big
uh difference or kind of line i would
draw is just like
there's the consumer applications to do
things with them outside of a financial
type asset and then there's like the
financial
asset type application i think that the
part where we've seen a lot of
improvement is
on the financial asset side so like
bitcoin being used
as a store value or a medium of exchange
what are all the things you can do if
that was a financial asset so can i
use it as collateral to get a us dollar
a loan right can i use it to earn
interest can i use it to you know do a
whole host of other things
that part to me feels like that's really
accelerated
especially over the last like two three
years um but when you talk about
what can i do with bitcoin uh in terms
of
you know can i go to the store and
quote-unquote buy coffee with it right
it's kind of the example everyone always
uses and like
some people just argue like that's not
really important right now right like
that's kind of like the
the last thing that needs to be
developed uh other people would argue
like
look there's some progress that's been
made but obviously there's not you know
in new york city millions of people
walking around spending bitcoin right
and so you can kind of try to unpack
some of this um and so i always think
through
on the crypto side specifically like how
much of it should look like
the traditional technology world right
like all the things that you and i would
think about whether it's consumer
enterprise whatever
versus no the point of this is to like
be different to kind of disrupt the
status quo right and so like the more it
looks
the same actually the least the the less
disruptive it's going to be right and i
frankly
uh i don't have a good answer for that
like like that's something i constantly
think through
um but but to your point in either one
of those scenarios you have to have
very user-friendly type interfaces
you've got to have products that are
intuitive
um and i think that you know what we saw
was the true technologists right the
people who aren't designers who aren't
kind of ux experts they aren't uh growth
marketers
and kind of all those you know important
roles but not the actual
technologists themselves uh they just
haven't been in the space
right up until maybe two years ago and
so now you're starting to see more and
more
come in products are improving but uh
you know compare that to
uh the traditional technology world and
still got a ways to go
yeah uh i think you made a bunch of
really
really good points in there like i i've
already my brain has started to think
through um just the low hanging fruit
that you described i mean if
there's a set of people out there which
it seems that there are
who are just holding you know bitcoin
for instance as a store of value
you know there should be some sort of
you know
some risk models that take that into
account as
uh as those folks are underwritten for
things like mortgages
um and i don't think that that's
happening yet and and
but it should be i mean you know i
you know even for myself selfishly like
you know if i want to refi our mortgage
uh it'll be great to have the crypto
holdings taken into account through
through some way of course interest
rates are very low right now but
yeah but you know or you know a down
payment through crypto or whatever it is
um and uh and those feel like the low
hanging fruit for
the set of folks that that hold it today
is as
purely a store of value yeah the two
pieces of this that are really
interesting so obviously
um it's become pretty public now that
it's like 63
of all existing bitcoin like in the
circulating supply haven't moved in the
last 12 months
so generally that just means like
there's a lot of people holding and not
trading or using it whatever um and uh
we invested in a company everyone who
listens will know it uh block fi
which uh one of the first products they
had was you deposit
uh bitcoin or crypto they take
possession
and then they give you a us dollar loan
against the collateral but what was so
fascinating when i looked at it was
you know let's take a car payment or a
car loan for example
basically if you're the bank and i'm the
person buying the car i come to you and
i say hey nikhil you know i'm a really
good person i promise i'll pay you back
give me the loan right
and uh the collateral will be the car
but i'm gonna take the car i'm gonna go
drive it around every day
and you'd say okay like make sure you
make the payments and if not i'm gonna
come find your car and you know
confiscate it and then liquidate it uh
and so like you as the bank actually
took quite a bit of risk right you had
to underwrite me then if something went
wrong you had to go find the
the collateral with this model basically
somebody gives the bitcoin
you hold on to it you give the us dollar
loan against it but it's also an over
collateralized loan so if i give you you
know 100 000
bitcoin you give me 30 000 loan if i do
anything stupid i don't pay you you know
whatever
you have the collateral already end is
over collateralized so with the
volatility and and we started to unpack
this and we're just like
wow this is a way better experience
for the lenders um because basically
it's the holy grail of lending right
it's like hey i'd love a over
collateralized loan where i hold on to
the collateral and basically have no
risk right or very little risk
and so i think that to your point it's
like okay that's one example
there's probably 50 others that people
will come up with where like this asset
provides a unique
mechanism um that doesn't exist in the
legacy world but we can take kind of
lending or spending or you know whatever
it is and apply it in a unique way
yeah and then the question is how to
make it really easy to understand
for you know both sides or the lender in
this case as well as for the consumer
and um and help them understand why it's
it's so powerful and and so much better
than the status quo
um and maybe that's actually the hardest
part of all this it's not
you know the the sort of product itself
more the
the messaging and positioning and um
education around it
as uh as somebody told me uh the word
cryptocurrency
is uh scary enough like crypto anything
people are like ah that's you know i'm
gonna get hacked
right is like kind of the the reaction
so it's an uphill battle
uh but before we uh we wrap up i ask
everyone the same two questions uh and
then you'll get a chance to ask me one
uh the first question is just what is
the most important book that you've ever
read
oh gosh so um
i'm assuming you have many yeah this is
really hard for me i think
um the first one that
that comes to mind is uh between the
world and me by ton easy coats and the
reason
i've been thinking about that book all
year is
um you know it talks about what it's
like to be
black in this country and um and just
the
experience um for all of
american history uh you know for
um for african americans here and for me
having grown up in the uk
and not being exposed to this history as
a kid
reading that book i think about five
years ago now
was uh was really powerful and really
educational
and helped me understand more about that
experience
as an outsider and i just think it
should be required reading for
everyone who lives here um and frankly
everyone you know
around the world so that's the one that
jumps out nothing related to
um business or technology but but really
really impactful for me
yeah that's a great suggestion second
question is more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
i'm a non-believer um you know
why you know i just think uh
i don't know i think that um this planet
is really unique from everything we can
tell and um and
uh you know i just think that uh
you know if if they were out there
somewhere then we would have
already found out but you know maybe we
are
just living in a simulation or something
and i'm completely wrong
elon obviously believes the the
simulation is more likely than
most others but uh we will see uh you
could ask me one question to uh to wrap
up what do you got for me
how's married life during the pandemic
and
yeah what's that been like now you got
married recently as well right
yeah we got married almost two years ago
now two years ago okay
we got married pre-pandemic so we had
that adjustment period and then suddenly
the pandemic
hit whereas you guys i think got married
during the time right we did
um i so everyone's a little bit
different we'd already lived together
uh for i don't know year and a half
almost two years maybe so like
a lot of the hey we're just moving in
together like
let's get used to living with each other
uh was already out of the way
um when it came to the wedding itself
uh we were already gonna have a small
wedding and
uh it was one of these things where we
we're going to get married in
april and so when everything hit in
march it's like
no way this is going to go on for four
weeks right like two weeks that's what
they said
you know two weeks later like okay let's
push the wedding back as far as we think
is
necessary there's no way this will still
be going on in july
july you know kind of june 15th or
whatever comes around we're like oh
this is not going to end anytime soon
and so we made the decision we said look
we'll just go get married ourselves just
the two of us
so know not even our parents were there
uh but it was one of these sich
you know kind of decisions of like am i
really gonna
postpone my life basically for a year
right and kind of
wait till uh the next summer we had a
lot of friends who did that but freso
was just
i don't know it just kind of it was for
us anyways right so it's like let's just
go get married
um but uh i i do tell the story uh
on the way to the quote-unquote wedding
uh my brother was the uh
um kind of the the not the priest but
like the officiant
and uh polino was already there and i
had to text her and i said uh
i may be a couple minutes late we
literally are in an uber and we're stuck
in a protest like we were driving down
the road and and in new york right
and so it was just you know a pandemic
all the social unrest like all this
stuff going on
and uh it just is not what you planned
right but uh but you kind of just deal
with it and then sometime next year
we'll have like a little
party or something so uh we can
celebrate with friends and family so
it'll be good but uh provides a lot of
good stories right
yeah it sounds unforgettable and i think
you know if you guys have
been able to figure out you know your
relationship and getting married and all
the stuff during this time i'm sure you
can conquer anything together so
hopefully that's the the great outside
right before we got married every
married couple we knew said the same
thing
uh if you lasted this long locked down
together you'll be fine
right all right all right nikki listen
where can we send people to find you on
the internet uh find out
uh more about what you're doing and kind
of your writing where would be the best
places to
to connect with you yeah i mean you know
on twitter
at nbt my initials um they also happen
to be the initials of
next big thing um so nbt.substack.com
is next big thing the newsletter and at
nvt on twitter
is where you can easily find me and
reach out to me
you're building a monopoly on those
three letters i like it
awesome man listen thank you so much for
doing this i'll have to do it again in
the future
sounds great thanks so much for having
me on